she came here because we're all stop it
we're all wise he was killed by
ultron wasn't he what did you say
welcome back to new rock one divisions
mcu conspiracy grows even deeper as
wanda pops out a couple
future young avengers and brady bunch
hell oh while the agents of sort are on
a mission
we think to sneak in some uninvited
cosplayers to a tv land convention
wtf or as we say here wanda
the never gets old
this is inside marvel it's our one
division
after show i'm eric voss talking about
one division episode three here with
jessica clements
i love the idea of calling it a brady
bunch hell uh
because i love the brady bunch so that
would be my hell i guess it'd be a good
hell
it'd be like oh no i hate living in the
brady bunch
and then god's like are you are you
serious every second i go yeah yeah
yeah sure jan i like i just say famous
quotes from the series all the time
absolutely fine with it is it uh the
rules of brady bunch hell where if you
say marsha martian marcia three times
marcia appears and tortures you
oh my god i'd say it like every day but
it's just how pretty she is
oh okay if it's that then no i don't
want that i don't want that in my room
just brushes her hair slowly in front of
me i'm gorgeous and i'm like i know that
marsha
god i am jan oh my god i knew it i knew
it
well we didn't get to see um wanna
maximoff get hit in the face with a
football today but we are going to
explain sword's mystery mission and try
to answer all the big questions we had
coming out of this episode
later today will be my in-depth shot by
shot breakdown of all the easter eggs
you might have missed in this episode
there were quite a few
and uh yes i am now wearing our new
latest obsession
shirt called an unusual couple you can
get it at newrocksourcemerch.com
i love the way it fits uh the design has
secret easter eggs revealed only
via augmented reality these are gonna
sell out fast uh
they they typically do because they're
really cool shirts and once they do
you know back in the blue dungeon vault
they go they're collectible items that's
kind of the rules of it so again new
yorkstarsmerch.com
but uh if you do get the shirt you'll
get the opportunity to write in
a custom shout out that will appear at
the bottom of these inside marvel
episodes we got a few down here
elizabeth
bollinger says for the children take a
shot
every time for this or what eric says
mephisto and you'll be like vision and
big red
yeah absolutely play along uh just make
sure you're home
you should be home anyway but absolutely
we love
that people are doing drinking games and
then uh
i don't know if this is legit but albert
barton says vanessa
via real i love you will you marry me
oh my god did we just get our first on
screen
i'm gonna be so mad if this isn't real
but then i'll also be happy if it's like
a cat
because it's two cats but also
congratulations oh
kitty marriage it's all it's a kind of
marriage but if it's not a kitty
marriage it's a human marriage
congratulations
we hope we hopefully you get a yes
um and if it is real send us a picture
if not we'll pretend this never happens
we can definitely play that trope of
like yeah we never said this
yeah what we need are some uh you know
we need some new rockstars hookups we
need some new rock stars
people who came together because of new
rock stars people who come together
because of new rock stars
and people who uh have babies we want
some in our babies
so i would love that let's let's build a
cult
as long as i beat tommy in this
competition then i'm fine with it
you guys better be more attracted to me
than tommy
i love tommy but it's competition yeah
everything's competitive
um i had to kill four different previous
new rock stars host to get this job
one of them still out there biting his
time until i'm old and weak
which is why i have to stay vigilant and
i'm always armed with
these guns
hey oh by the way our merch partners
epicurus shop have also released a
companion shirt
um so if you want to keep this unusual
couple together you totally can and you
totally should want to give them
together
uh jump on that one as well newark's
merch.com um
okay jessica let's talk about episode
three what happened this episode okay
you guys i told you last time i'm bad at
summarizing so i wrote it down this time
i'm gonna read it
uh secondly just so you guys did if you
didn't catch on
i did my like makeup as an homage this
episode because monica's makeup was
astounding
very nice thank you not the hair wish i
could have done the fro but i couldn't
do it because the hair is in and it's
not coming out
but let's get into it so this episode
is truly insane it really starts like
you start recognizing what it is
if you watch episode one and two and
we're really confused it's starting to
break it down and you're starting to
actually understand what's going on
so we uh we started with the 70s groovy
vision and pregnant wanda and a brady
bunch-ish like opening instead of
squares though they get hexagons
hexagons they're bad every every person
that came at me about not talking about
the hexagons last time i understand i
did wrong
because the hexagons are big in this
episode apparently they're a very big
deal
they're a huge deal and i definitely
just said yeah there's hexagons what
about it
they're shapes i'm sorry i take it all
back
so vision and wanda are visited by their
doctor who tells them that they're four
months pregnant which is
super quick vision walks the doctor then
out
it's too fast i wish it worked like that
but it does not
so the vision then walks the doctor out
and they saw herb cutting the hedges and
herb is cutting the hedges straight to
the brick wall like a weirdo
that isn't my man herb no herb
herb went my man it's just cut into the
brick wall
and vision's like okay this is weird
re-enters his home to see wanda even
more pregnant she's now reached
from four months to six months and he
was gone for maybe 30 seconds
so it's already going crazy in haywire
every time we see wanda she's having
like any kind of cramps any kind of like
discomfort or false labor
something weird happens to the
surrounding either the lights go out uh
water is triggered uh just like
everything in the house is going bonkers
and that's the slapstick comedy that
we're getting
in this episode i love it we get a small
moment when vision recognizes all the
weird stuff happening and once he says i
think there's something wrong here ronda
we cut back to the beginning of the
conversation
a glitch we don't know it could have
been a skip in the tape
no one knows that glitch i really had to
pause and like rewind and be like oh no
that was meant to be there because you
know
internet my internet i thought i was
like spectrum like i was truly like
they did it again and i and then i was
like oh yeah i forgot what the show's
about
which i'm sure everybody was caught okay
so then wanda begins going into actual
labor vision runs to the doctor
promptly she's visited by geraldine
monica and a silly uninvited stork
that store storks just have an open
invitation to everyone's home
they're really the worst guest and i'm
such a dummy i was like why is there a
hair in here and i was like oh
it's a store who also won't
doing bringing babies in the room i said
is that a pterodactyl i
i just don't know anything that has
wings but it won't disappear with the
red hand smoke
wanda keeps trying to get it to
disappear and it will not disappear it
was like
all of your attacks are futile against
me it was truly a pokemon
i'm a storm you didn't understand i
truly was so stupid i was like is this
an eagle i truly did not understand
until the second time i watched it
do you not know what birds are jessica
i'm not showing you my notes but i wrote
down three different birds it could have
been
and then i was like oh it's a stork this
is why you gotta play wingspan with me
the best board game in the world
teaches you all about different birds
not really if you have to read the cards
to learn
oh i forget to do that no i'm not going
to do that i can't i can't i don't have
time
so then wanda goes into actual labor and
gives birth with the help of geraldine
when vision and the doctor enter
assisting that with the second birth
it's twins
go figure tommy and billy they named
them both yeah
we got some confirmation that we got a
confirmation t on the refrigerator that
didn't really look like a t it is a t
it's a wiccan and speed it looks like
they're going one is definitely not
different colors uh which i held onto
i was like wasn't one green okay so all
is great okay so
right all is great until wanda and
geraldine are alone and wanda and what
seemingly is a heart to heart reveal
she's a twin
and she had a brother named pietro that
died when geraldine cuts in and says he
was killed by ultron wasn't he
that i would say his name i said you
said it all hell's about to break
loose so outside we get vision talking
to urban agnes who are asking way too
many questions and being super
suspicious about geraldine being left
alone with wanda
they say geraldine has no husband no
family no home in her town
herb begins to explain she came here
because we're all
what no one knows because agnes
immediately
cuts in and goes stop stop and looks at
him yeah stop it
and yeah that's what deborah joe rupp's
character was saying in episode one stop
it
stop it stop stop it you stop it oh my
god i didn't even thought about it
you stopped it i didn't think about this
see this is why i needed you i didn't
know it was a stork and i didn't think
about that thing but now i think about
it
so wanda and geraldine are having this
crazy uncomfortable conversation almost
interrogation of geraldine
where it's obvious that like wanda is
now like the bad cop
and geraldine is just an innocent victim
in all this she's like i would like to
go home
right now please yeah she and she's like
no where did you come from where did you
do this
wanda becomes completely hostile and
tells jared and she thinks she should
leave
wanda recognizes geraldine's necklace
that is the symbol for
sword that we all talked about earlier
and geraldine becomes tongue-tied trying
to answer but also confused next thing
we know vision enters the home and
geraldine gets
shot out of a cosmic bubble to a bunch
of soldiers and lights and helicopters
outside that we saw in the trailer
yes the forces of sword uh
hey uh we let's not forget dr nielsen
with his sexist
views oh we make it into fruit because
it's easier for their tiny brains and
then
you can be a nurse young lady a nurse
one day when she just finished talking
about the amazing promotion she already
got
yeah yeah he's a bottle and then also i
forgot to bring it up but i will bring
it up
the commercial which we will go into we
will definitely go into but yes there is
another commercial in this episode
it's about uh just taking time to
yourself yeah hydra
soak this one was not even trying to be
subtle it's just like remember hydra
yeah yeah you remember hiding that's
soap so yes another super fun episode uh
lots of mystery but i feel like the most
mysterious stuff like last episode with
the beekeeper this episode with the
forces of sword is all stuff that we saw
in the trailer so it's like
okay haven't totally gotten more context
about this
other than like wanda's attitude right
like
she seemed to have some aggression as
you said like
we need to dive into this because
there's so many theories that came up
because of this episode
where i was like maybe there is no
villain maybe wanda is the only person
in there and we're just coming up with
nightmare
grim reaper and like emma festo and
maybe it's just her
but let's let's get into it because i
truly need to talk it out
yeah so what was we think the big um uh
wtf coming out of this episode oh
wtf is sword what the wanda the one to
the [ __ ] sword and what is their
mission
yeah um so i think this one thing that
confused me more about this episode than
i was at the start of the series is it
kind of confirms that there are multiple
forces at work here like i used to think
that you know
everybody was drinking the same kool-aid
and then i thought
you know maybe it's one envision versus
the community but now it looks like
there are five
different teams with different motives
so just to break those down quickly we
got wanda who seems to be on a team of
her own
uh a team of her own uh directed by
penny marshall
uh she really just seems to want to live
in west view
with vision have kids without being out
as a superhero and she's only a little
suspicious
but i don't think she's on the same team
as vision who i would say is on team two
he is way more confused worried uh
he seems super suspicious of this town
more than wanda is
uh but his goal is to just support wanda
he's kind of attached to her whatever
she wants he wants
but he is of a different level of
cognition than she is
[Music]
the third team is just west view the
community
and that includes uh herb norm the
hearts
phil dottie bev dr nielsen his wife
others
it seems like they want the children
they're for the children
um and they seem to be prone to
glitching
however they know something herb knows
something right
um so they're of a different level of
condition than
vision is then we get agnes on team four
she seems to have a completely separate
agenda from the rest of the
town and definitely separate from wander
vision because she
turns wanda and vision against other
people like dottie
uh like geraldine and monica if she was
part of the town of west views thing
she wouldn't try to turn wanda against
dottie in episode two
she would have some other kind of like
uh focus
um and then the fifth team is one we're
about to talk about sword um
that includes monica and the beekeeper
jimmy wu darcy lewis
those are all the people we see at the
outside at the end of the episode who
are trying to break
into this pocket reality so just to
rewind the clock on sword you've been
seeing various sightings of sword the
logo right the
circle with the sword coming up through
it on the monitor room at the end of
episode one on that toy helicopter the
beekeeper's suit had a sword logo on the
back monica's necklace
this episode and this episode we see
their whole exterior perimeter and their
whole military style camp
okay so what is sword sword is the
organizational offshoot of shield in the
marvel comics it stands for in the
comics at least sentient world
observation
and response department it's
headquartered on a space station called
the peak in earth's orbit it kind of
focuses on extraterrestrial threats
however in the mcu we've gotten a hint
that sword might instead stand for
sentient weapon observation and response
department that comes from a social
media leak of a digital trading card
it's not yet confirmed
but we could see that being very likely
uh wanda is
wanda and vision are kind of sentient
weapons um
all avengers in a way are sentient
weapons technically um
so what we know about sword so far is we
think it is a nick fury
joint uh separate from shield the
spider-man far from home
post-credit scene shows fury on that
squirrel space station we think that
might be the peak
uh and we know that monica rambo is part
of this sword organization we last saw
her
with fury and the squirrels in captain
marvel when she was a kid um
so presumably that was kind of the
origins of sword in that final scene
now previously we have assumed in this
show that sword is investigating this
phenomenon from the outside and trying
to free
wanda from it and that's why sword is
sending in agents like monica and the
beekeeper to try to rescue her to try to
break the bubble sometimes it seems like
sword might have actually helped wanda
create the solution but
based on the way wanda reacts to each
sword sighting i think we can assume
that she and sword are not on the same
page
uh wanda does not want this illusion to
end she's kind of like cipher in the
matrix right
ignorance is bliss now sword's mission
is to break wanda free of this spell by
identifying which dark force she
partnered with to create it
the voice of the radio asks who is doing
this to you
i think we can assume that who is agnes
and maybe the demonic or dark entity she
serves
whether it's the grim reaper or mephisto
i made another video on that but i think
that is why monica is trying to supplant
agnes
as wanda's best friend she's trying to
drive a wedge between them
and that's why agnes finds that
closeness so
threatening but jessica do you think
there's any other kind of aspect to
sword's mission on the show or is there
another way to interpret what they're
doing
so this is where i started getting i was
like okay
i need to go back and re-watch the other
two episodes after people are getting at
me about the hexagon i was like the
hexagon and then i watched this episode
i was like okay the hexagon is a big
deal let me go be i can re-watch it so
and every time i look down just for
everybody's knowledge i have my notes
below me of like what i was writing
during the show
so when i was watching it and i was like
okay let's get back to the beekeeper for
us
a hot second just a quick second right
so i was immediately like i wrote down
in my notes i was like swarm or aim
and then i was like i think it's just
funny if you swarm i do think he can't
be aimed because it's the sword person
like we saw the sword logo on the back
but then i was also like
i don't think i don't think marvel would
do this again but what if it's possible
that someone again
from there like that time from hydra uh
from aim
has now broken into shield and is
working as like
presumably this is still a good team but
there's someone undercover that's trying
to get to the more information that's
in there even if it is like another
entity if it's like mafester or
something i think
i was like that could be a possibility
we could have been doing another
introduction to aim because we didn't
really
get we did get them in iron man 3 but we
didn't get them a lot in other than the
video games
so i was like what if they're just like
what if we get another break-in
there's a possibility that that could be
like the case that's going on
and then that would give more reason for
like or and then i was also like
hexagons hex watch it be just some witch
stuff that i'm just
not like not catching on to right but
that aim thing started hitting me
because i was like that could be an
homage to aim
because they all wear yellow suits they
are technically like evil and they could
be going implemented into hydra again or
as hydra into a swarm this time instead
of shield like last time
i was like they could be doing that also
those strucker applied
all the strucker stuff and i was like i
wasn't keeping this in mind that
striker's not a good person so i was
like
right this could just be like we think
that it's swarm
but it could be someone doing corrupt
[ __ ] within swarm
making it just worse on the inside for
wanda i
i see the arguments about aim uh people
been sharing that
and i know i'm gonna sound
self-contradictory here
uh the fact that ames logo is a hexagon
i don't think it's connected to the
hexagons of this show
in some cases hexagons are just a
natural shape that people work in a logo
and they just fit together naturally and
that's we see that all over the mcu
there's like the the universal neural
transportation network
is made up of hexagons that doesn't
immediately mean it's connected
but when we see hexagons within this
show
i think we can assume those are
connected um the only reason i
my gut tells me it's not aim is that
we're already meeting a new organization
with sword in this show
are they really going to bring in
another organization
that was from iron man 3 advanced idea
mechanics those aldrich killians weapons
organization
i don't know i i something tells me it i
doubt it i get that i get that i'm
trying to like
it was just like everything i was like
we have to piece it together somehow but
then i'm also like
watching more of it and we can get into
this later watching more of it i was
like what if there is no villain but
wanda what if wanda is doing all of this
on her own
i was like there is a possum because
agnes is obviously afraid of her too
agnes wasn't like stop it angry she was
like stop it please
like stop it we're gonna get yeah and
they were like it was like
that reckoning of just like they're
afraid for geraldine
because she's in there with wanda
wanda's not in there with geraldine
like she's in there right yeah yeah yeah
and yeah
it was like and so i was just like there
has to be a reason this is all connected
but maybe agnes isn't working with
mephisto
maybe she's just like a deep deep part
of like wanda's memory
and with all that's happening right now
she was just one of those many people
that were brought back and she's like
actually i have another side note to
this but i know that it's in like the
next our next topic so we can slide into
it if we want yeah oh for sure yeah we
can do that just some conclusions things
you need to know about sword for now
heading forward in the series sword is
this separate marvel entity it's kind of
going to be the new
shield of the mcu in this show they are
it looks like good guys just trying to
help wander at least control her if she
is kind of the villain of the series um
and they are not on the same side of the
rest of west view
in agnes it's clear that uh the town of
west view views
these uh this outside entity as a
hostile presence
so i think there's there's like a
dividing line between them
so just think of sword as like kind of
the observers and
the the helpers kind of the cops outside
of the hostas situation
who are just trying to call in to the um
hostage taker to try to negotiate with
them also side note
when i was watching that scene i paused
it so many times on the very end
i will i'll take the fact that sword
brought in
those like lights but then i was also
like this looks like it's a football
field
and it looks like ronda literally walked
into a town
and took it over and that's why i think
like herb's last words could have been
like we're all trapped because there
were just people of this town that
wanted to force to become
in her freaking freaking chaotic world
yeah there's you can see those lights
and you can see a little house from the
house yeah
i was like so it tells us that it's not
just like an empty field that they're
looking in at it's a town that was
already there before
the illusion started to come up 100
i was going crazy with it um we're going
to keep talking about uh this episode
first we just want to thank some people
who helped us make it
uh thank you to blue chew for sponsoring
this episode guys do you remember the
days when you were always
ready to go uh if whether you're human
or synthezoid
your purple parts are gonna do some
pleasing
well now you can be ready to go whenever
you need to you can increase
your performance and get that extra
confidence in bed with bluechew.com
that's blue like the color blue
blue chew brings you the first chewable
with the same fda approved active
ingredients as viagra and cialis you
take them any time day or night even on
a full stomach so you can be ready
to go whenever an opportunity arises
even if you have to
make a baby that just dates and uh is
delivered within 24 hours
i don't know if blue chew can help you
do that you'd have to be a fictional
character
but hey i'm into it if you could benefit
from more confidence where it counts
blue chew
is the fast and easy way to enhance your
performance blue chew is prescribed
online by licensed physicians so you
don't have to go to the doctor's office
or wait in line at the pharmacy
and it ships right to your door in a
discreet package they are made in the
usa
and since bluetooth repairs and ships
direct they're cheaper than the pharmacy
no awkwardness and you don't have to
leave the house and right now we have a
special deal for our listeners
visit bluechew.com and get your first
shipment for free when you use our
special promo code wandavision
just pay five dollars shipping again
that's b l u e
chew dot com promo code one division to
try it free we also want to thank our
friends at helix sleep for sponsoring
this episode
we have been losing some sleep trying to
figure out the mysteries of wanda vision
but we shouldn't be losing sleep because
of a bad mattress
helix sleep has a quiz that takes two
minutes just two minutes to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
soft medium or firm mattress mattress is
great if you sleep hot or even mattress
for plus size folks
the quiz match me with the dusk luxe
helix mattress because
i wanted a medium firm mattress with
lumbar support that sleeps cool
and they checked all those boxes and i
have like the perfect mattress now i've
been sleeping great ever since i got it
i love it
it's a huge upgrade over my old weird
mattress that probably needed to be
taken out in the back and shot
years ago uh the mattress ships free
right to your door helix was awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by gq and wired
magazine just go to helixsleep.com
mandalorian i know it's uh the old url
but it's still
specific to new rock stars take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they will
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
love it
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners
at helix sleep.com mandalorian
i know a different show than this one
but it is the new rockstars url and we
want them to know that we sing it okay
back to this episode three of wand
division what's our next wtf wtf
uh what's her about to say she came here
because we're all
what yeah yeah that came through
because we are all it had to be trapped
they're all trapped they're all trapped
like they're all trapped trapped is
where my mind went to
because that just came after that uh the
doctor said it's so hard to escape from
a small town
those key words escape and if that's the
truth then maybe
uh monica rambo's mission and sword's
mission isn't just to
save wanda it's to save all these people
in this town too that is 100
yeah okay so if we do go off the theory
that she did walk into this town and
literally just corrupt everything
and like turned everything into her own
thing that it would be it would make
sense that sometimes these people come
out of consciousness
or they're playing very hard because
they're afraid of what wanda might do to
them
because it seems like how would because
we all thought that they were all just
like under the spell
they were all like turned into like
these people right what if they're not
actually turned into anything and
they're just out of fear
like just playing along playing the
games that's why dottie cut herself and
was just like
um i don't wanna i don't want you to
throw me out of this bubble and kill me
too
like uh yeah it's it's i think there
must be some kind of trance or spell
because uh if so they would all have to
be amazing actors
like to to convince them so much there's
some kind of magic at play
because herb was uh was herb just having
a nervous breakdown then if he was uh
cutting into the wall
or he seemed like his eyes were wide he
was
just in a different place so maybe once
she realized geraldine wasn't supposed
to be there that's when people all were
like starting to wake up because she was
like
wait a minute you're definitely not
supposed to be here oh
maybe yeah yeah yeah possibly another
theory i thought for what he's going to
say is uh she came here because we're
all
dead like going back
they're all ghosts we shouldn't be alive
this is a youth theory i don't agree
with that hey i'll take a me theory my
me
theories have been uh right sometimes
other times i've barfed them back up
it's a graveyard they threw the corpses
in there
uh so it seems like uh trapped is the
the right answer
but it could also be dead it could also
be like we're oh because we're all
fake or we're all demons or we're all
synthezoids are they all robots yeah he
would say that's so
like melanchol we're all robots like oh
okay all artificial um
but uh the flip side of this question
let's talk about wanda the [ __ ]
was agnes reaction to her when she said
stop it
jessica she looks scared so do you think
agnes is a victim
of this as well okay okay
okay let's talk about a little bit and
i know that we wrote this down as one of
the wtf so i'm sorry to like jump into
it a little early
but the fact is so i read
a little bit i never finished it which
is why i looked up i looked it up again
and i'm so
so so so so sorry to the fans watching
because they're like
this woman talks about wand division but
she don't read all the comics
so i i read i think i did half of james
robinson
james robinson scarlet witch vol 1 where
they talk about the witches road
right so i looked into it more because i
was like let's look into this so in that
issue agnes is just a freaking ghost
right
that wanda like is only talking to every
time and
eventually she's resurrected by the
inner goddess
which is hakate and so i was like
what if she like is technically
resurrected or something in this world
by wanda
but she's like afraid of going back or
just afraid of what she'll do because
she's the only person that ultimately
knows wanda's huge powers
or well like she everyone knows but
she's like i
lived with this woman like i know i
lived for 10 000 years like i know what
her powers are like
so she completely is scared and it's
when they had that inner goddess part
with the hydra soak i was like
okay so agnes is just brought back by
wanda because
like going along james robinson's like
storyline of scarlet witch
number one number number one so uh
number one
so i think like we should be looking at
that comic book anyone that's fans out
there please
look into it more than i did because i
was like i didn't have time to look and
see if james robinson had any ties to
the like
the series if they asked him questions
or anything because his storyline is
completely different like
wanda's mom is in it so it's like a
different story
but they kind of do a nod to it
just saying just you know i think for me
it was the fact that agnes was turned
away from vision in that moment and that
fear in her eyes was something she
didn't want vision to see so this
fear this stop it it was not a
performance it felt real
and it reminds me of that uh shot we've
seen in trailer footage where she's
scared and she turns to vision she goes
are you here to save us
uh because you're an avenger you're dead
you know like
there's and she has a big laugh so it's
i'm not really sure what
uh what agnes deal is she's scared
she was i think she's a little afraid of
of wanda and what i think is that
agnes has partnered with wanda um but
that whatever their partnership was
whether it was like together they're
working on a spell to resurrect vision
that has gone out of control and agnes
is like
this [ __ ] is too powerful i don't want
to upset her she could destroy all of us
so like let's just like play along with
this just make wanda happy
uh what have i gotten myself into i
mentioned it earlier i think but it was
like
her entire job in this series so far is
to keep wanda happy
like that's all agnes has been keeping
her under control
like she's been just like coming in at
the right moments of like flusteredness
to be like
hey what's going on like uh so i'm like
yeah she's truly there
to keep her happy and now that she's
alone with someone that wasn't supposed
to be in that world she's like
i can't go in there i can't just jump in
there maybe that's what she was trying
to add
or ralph a herb about she was like i
can't just run in that house now like
geraldine's in there
i have to say i love that you keep
calling him herb as if like you know
he's parsley or something
we should just call him herb he no he is
now herb now
he's herb herb or herb
basil hey who else loves herbs the devil
mephisto
keep going let's keep going uh we gotta
talk about this glitch
uh this glitch definitely broke my brain
because yeah we've seen like uh meta
production stuff before every episode
ends with
like the tv uh wipe uh wanda
rewound the footage within the episode
last but this one
it's almost like disney and the marvel
team was trying to confuse us in this
moment
they wanted everyone to pause and rewind
and make sure
it is what they see uh do we think that
uh first off there might have been other
glitches that we overlooked
but then secondly does this tell us
something about the nature of this world
it is weird that episode one ended with
a sword agent i think it was darcy lewis
by the way watching that
on tv is it possible that what we are
watching from within the reality
is being broadcasted to tv in the local
area
and that's how sword detected it they're
like whoa people's tv land reruns
have an avenger in it the hell is going
on
like is all of things that were seen
within it
um being broadcasted out to random
people's houses
and that's what we're looking at that
would be that's
might be the most rogues theory ever
that's such a crazy idea
i like the idea of assuming that was
darcy lewis because
in all of the trailer that she's been in
it's like her always flustered like
trying to like get something across so
it could be her
like trying to tell like you guys aren't
listening to me i
i wrote down notes i found out what
what's happening over there
that'd be insane also this glitch made
me feel like
which is probably not true don't hold on
to this that it didn't come from
wanda because the all the other glitch
that happened in the second episode she
said no
we rewound this one she just had the
exact same
face unless it was just yeah for her to
be like i don't want you no
you're right you're right she was
listening to vision she wanted to hear
what vision was getting at in that
moment so
something else caused that unless my
theory is true
and that she created vision and so their
minds are
literally taped together everything she
says he does everything he does she says
like it's there
yes he's an improviser but he's also
just one with her yeah and
when his face because he obviously
seemed really shook he was like
something's going on here wanda maybe
that was visions like
cut back to the beginning instead of
wandas but they're both the same mind
they're both the same person
because wanda made him up it's it's a
give and take relationship that's why i
think there was this moment where she
goes oh did i do
that kind of thing it wasn't did i do
that wasn't an urkel reference but
she did say like oh i didn't even
realize i could do that like when they
were
decorating the nursery so like i think
that was a signal to us that
wanda is somewhat a controller's reality
but not totally in control of it she has
made some kind of deal with the devil
either the literal devil or someone you
know akin to them
who um has kind of made it a give and
take relationship with west view
sometimes westview correct stuff
sometimes wanda correct stuff but there
is that lever there in someone's hand
two different hands are wrestling on
that joystick
also the the people that found that part
the grim reaper's helmet
in um the second episode i was like if i
see the grim reaper i'm gonna be a
little irritated
and we keep bringing in so many villains
and i'm like can we just leave it at one
can we leave it a minute yeah that's
kind of the the leading sentiment right
now is that it's not mephisto it's the
grim reaper
um there's more proof for that there is
definitely more proof of the grim reaper
especially i think people are seeing
signs of like wonder man who is the grim
reaper's brother
and this all might be a plot to take uh
visions consciousness and reincarnate it
and wonder man the reason i hope it's
not a literal adaptation of that is that
is such a
goofy plot from that marvel from
avengers 102.
and it's one of these things where if
that ends up being what it is if it's
just literally that
people who are watching one division
right now just loving this mystery are
gonna be like
that sucks it's one of these things
where like
marvel fans watch these shows and i'm
one of them and thinks
oh there are some similarities to this
one random comic from the 80s or 90s
that i read
and then kevin feige is just going to do
exactly that that's never the case
i don't care what glaring easter eggs
there are he always
does something that will appeal to a
broad audience who does not read the
comics
so that's why i'm still leaning against
this grim reaper thing
it's not gonna be exactly that it may be
based on that it may be similar to that
it may be more that than a fiscal so the
equivalent to that
is okay so yeah we're trying to figure
out who the villain is so i understand
it could be grim reaper just because of
that helmet being shown and a couple
other things
but also in that same intro they had um
it said like
auntie a's like kitty litter for
for agonist and then they had bova milk
for the
cow that raised her in the comics so i
was like there's a lot of they're just
like giving like a nod to like
we saw we read the comic books too
because when they do this the there's
like another animator who works on that
jack shaffer the show runner uh
overlooked it and was probably like yeah
kevin fight he's like yeah sure
but those animators will sneak in all
kinds of stuff we break down rick and
morty on this channel
and all the time without dan harmon or
justin roiland signing off on it
they'll put in references to south park
or the simpsons and stuff and the
animator will be like yeah i just threw
that in there
and then uh hartman will be like yeah
okay let's talk about uh our fifth
wanda the uh that hydra soaked
commercial you had some ideas for
that find the inner goddess within what
do we think it is
it is straight there written in the
stars
it has when they said find the inner
goddess in you
the inner goddess was hikate or i'm
sorry i'm so sorry if i'm pronouncing
that god is wrong i
am terrible at pronouncing anyone's name
but um it definitely is
her the goddess of witchcraft because
even
in the storyline that james robinson had
she got her powers and same with agnes
they got their powers from that woman
and when those and that when she noticed
her powers were being weakened she was
like someone's
messing with it and i need to go figure
out who it is it was declan
but like she was like i need to go
figure out who it is so i was like i
think that
i don't i don't know if that's gonna
have a severe tie i think it's just more
about the hydra meaning
more than anything but the inner goddess
part is like her inner goddess is her
magic it's her witchcraft
and i think we should not not knock that
or like not like
acknowledge that that's what was said
yeah whether it's that specific
character or just like the fact that
uh wanda was cursed by chatham when she
was a baby yeah and has always kind of
had this god level power she's an omega
level mutant he's a guy
so maybe find that goddess within is
kind of like telling this
marvel goddess like you are
far more powerful than most other
characters in this universe
find that inner goddess and uh and she
is basically the goddess of this pocket
reality
so i think it's kind of a message there
also uh
it probably was not meant to do this but
i feel like the director noticed it and
was like
yeah let's keep it like that phil phil
came in with another funny one-liner
phil coming in with the mustache man
with a funny joke he was reading a
newspaper and before the lights went out
it said something like
first fire hydrant or a second a second
fire hydrant added on yeah the street
and it was folded so you saw
hydra instead of hydrant and i was like
whoa
jessica that's going in the breakdown
you're getting the credit for that one
i was so mad because i was like the
director definitely noticed that and was
just like
okay i don't know i don't know i could
see the direct i could see that going
either way
oh but i love it it is now an easter egg
he's like thank you
thank you jessica clemens noticed it
but that was another time hydra's
brought up our final one
what's going on with wanda why do you
think uh monica
mentioning ultron killed pietro
triggered wanda so much
she knew she had a twin she must have
known some parts of her back why
is monica saying that piss her off i
think she just
put that which i mean probably a lot of
people would if their twin died
shove that so deep down and then she
also lost
vision she lost literally all the loves
of her life
she believed in ultron and then ultron
like showed like she found out that he
was just trying to destroy
every human and she was like everybody i
fall for
keeps dying or just becomes evil and so
i that just triggered it it just woke
her up from that
this dream that she's in yeah i think uh
you were saying this earlier but this
ending
was the the most hint we have gotten
that wanda could just be the villain of
the series uh because
man uh the fact that everyone was so
afraid of her it felt very anthony
fremont in that twilight zone episode
the kid who can just like manifest all
of reality around him read people's
minds
and everyone better say very good
anthony and do whatever he wants it
feels like that's who she was
and the fact that she was just rocking
these babies didn't that feel like the
ending of rosemary's baby
and the screen got wider it went from a
movie
yeah like it felt like she was weirdly
calm and vision was scared vision was
terrified and i can't wait till the
fourth episode
would be like vision's gonna start
recognizing like
there's something like there's gonna be
a i can't wait for the glitch to happen
and he's gonna be like what just
happened he's gonna like acknowledge
there was a glitch he's gonna be like
no that wasn't normal wanda what the
hell's happening here like yeah he was
scared of her too and uh i from what we
could probably guess next week will be
the uh the 80s family ties or full house
episode so the babies will be like a
little older
yeah agnes looks like she's gonna be the
kimmy gibbler
um vision looks more confused than he
normally
is um so we'll see
i don't know if we've seen vision and
wanda together
and a lot of the other footage from the
latest episodes like
uh the 90s one wanda looks like she's
alone the 2000's modern family one
wanda's alone in the house that's true
vision is walking around
trick-or-treating you don't see them
together
in some of the later sitcoms so they
might wait until that trick-or-treat
episode
i cannot wait for that trick-or-treat i
feel like that episode is gonna unravel
so much also i need to know what sword
is actually do i can't
i'm glad we finally saw a sword because
now we're gonna be like
oh monica storyline we're gonna figure
out what swords actually doing
yeah i'm so excited for the fourth
episode well as always
we're gonna close out this episode by
checking back in with our segment
what the devil in which we're gonna run
down some possible clues in sightings of
mephisto
only mephisto no one else and again we
know that episode two had that big grim
reaper easter egg this
might um evolve into a segment called
uh getting grammar i don't know oh
that's a good one
grim miss are we stealing from
mcdonald's completely
or how about uh grim and barrett oh
that's a good one okay we get another
one but for now we're still kind of on
leaning towards mephisto
one clue that i saw was when agnes said
ralph looks better in the dark
it could go either way what does that
mean does that mean dark robes grim
reaper
or something else you know i don't know
um but what did you make of in the
opening
titles that old withered red book that
vision was reading just called pregnancy
why did that book look
so uh dilapidated because you see that
dark shaded
like it's obviously a figure and i was
trying so hard to like zoom in but my
phone was not having it
it was not having it so if there is
someone that has that computer
technology please tell me what it said
we'll talk about in the breakdown
but that is something i feel like that
could like
is that the dark hold you know is that
some kind of cursed book
that uh that's the actual book that
brought vision back to life
we'll see third detail more sixes more
hexagons we saw that in the opening
scene
um some people pointed out how there are
six prongs on wanda's ruby ring you
don't need six prongs you can get away
with four i know this i just went
engagement ring shopping
so why six prongs i don't know if it is
anything
but uh a fourth detail some of our
friends on discord actually found this
and i think some other people read it
saw it as well
from the first episode the toaster in
the commercial um that was
the first toaster the one that broke the
before toaster it has a symbol
when it's flipped upside down a six six
six so it is mafesto good to know cool
got it
or it's something or it's all of it it's
it's mafesto now that
that tied it in that put it in there put
it in the middle i actually
asked uh the actor our good buddy
ethmoir enriquez about this in uh
yesterday's video so be sure to go watch
it
well that is it for this uh episode of
inside marvel one division after show
we'll be back next week to break down
the biggest uh
one of the from episode four uh jessica
thank you so much for joining me
you can follow jessica at lulu
underscore clemens it's not lulu
clement's one word lulu underscore
it is on twitter everywhere else it's
lulu clemens as one word
oh yeah well on twitter thank you for
clearing it up
got it because the other lulu clements
on twitter had her account suspended so
people were like what
yeah it was someone that tried to take
it was someone that tried to take my
twitter a long time ago and i
had maybe 30 followers it wasn't
anything wow
if you see them say anything mean it
wasn't me it was i'm trying to take my
dang name you can follow me
at ea boss and follow new rockstar
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcast subscribe to
uh new york six here on youtube and
we're gonna close with our favorite
moment of the episode do these earrings
make me look fat
oh thank god
[Music]
you